[Music]  Kylie Jenner and Travis Scott enjoy  parents night out as the proud mama  shares more adorable snaps of their baby  girls storming Kylie and Travis were  spotted in the rapper's hometown of  Houston Texas Wednesday night sitting  courtside at the Rockets vs.  Timberwolves game the 20 year old  reality star looked casual in a baggy  black t-shirt and loose-fitting pants  but as always her hair and makeup on  point  StuH earlier in the day Kylie was ever  the doting mom posting cute moments like  this on snapchat it's not the only  recent night out for the new parents  over the weekend they were spotted livin  it up at Coachella with Nicki Minaj and  chance the rapper  [Music]  [Applause]